hello guys and welcome back to
jaegerists
in today's video we will be going
through the story of aaron yeager
leave a like on this video and subscribe
to our channel if you want to see more
content like this
aaron was born in shiganshan district on
march 30th 835
in the southern region of walmareia to
carla jaeger and grisha jaeger
he had a few friends although his best
friend was armin alert whom he often
defended from the neighborhood bullies
armin inspired his passion to leave the
walls and travel by showing him a hidden
book about the outside world
he dreamed of joining the survey corps
as soon as he reached the enlistment age
in order to see the outside world
because of his dream aaron and armin
were frequently regarded as heretics and
harassed
constantly by other children when aaron
was nine years old he accompanied his
father on a house call to the ackermann
family's house
only to find both parents murdered and
their daughter mikasa missing
fearing the worst dr yeager instructed
aaron to stay within the house while he
fetched the military police
aaron however tracked the robbers to a
small cabin in the forest behind the
house
thinking quickly aaron feigned distress
and claimed that he was lost
as one of the robbers approached aaron
he pulled out a hidden knife and stabbed
the man
as the second man went after him with an
axe aaron charged him with a makeshift
spear
piercing him in the shoulder once he was
down aaron proceeded to stab him to
death in a wild frenzy while mikasa
looked on
as aaron untied her in the aftermath he
was caught off guard by a third
robber who proceeded to strangle him
aaron urged mikasa who was frozen in
fear to fight back
warning her that they would both be
killed if she did nothing as
aaron began to lose consciousness mikasa
finally lost all
inhibition and lunged at their attacker
stabbing him through the heart and
killing him
when dr jaeger eventually returned with
the mps he took aaron aside
scolding him angrily for his reckless
behavior while aaron was genuinely sorry
for upsetting his father
he expressed no remorse whatsoever for
killing the robbers
when mikasa remarked that she was cold
aaron gave her the scarf from his own
neck
and when dr jaeger invited mikasa to
live with their family from then on
aaron accepted her without hesitation
tugging on her sleeve and shyly
insisting that they return
home after aaron is woken from a
nightmare by mikasa
the two walk home through shiganshinan
they are harassed by haines
who begins teasing aaron for having
apparently cried in his sleep
aaron is annoyed to see that haines and
his friends are slacking off on the job
and refuses to be placated by their
claims that the titans will never breach
while maria
leaving haines behind the children stop
again to watch the survey corps return
from an expedition and aaron has crest
fallen to see that the corps has
returned defeated
upon returning home mikasa reveals to
aaron's mother that he wants to join the
survey corps
carla forbids him from joining due to
the course high mortality rate and begs
grecia to talk some sense into his son
grecia ignores her objections and
instead announces that he will be
leaving for a few days on a trip
promising airing that when he gets back
he will show the boy what he has hidden
in the basement of their home
enthralled aaron joins his mother and
mikasa in waving him off
carla reminds him that she will not
allow him to join the survey corps and
they exchange a heated argument before
he runs off
aaron and mikasa scare off bullies
harassing armin and the three stroll
through shiganshinan and settle by the
riverbank
armin deduces that aaron's parents found
out he wants to join the survey corps
before criticizing the widespread belief
that it is impossible for the titans to
breach the walls
suddenly lightning strikes and an
earthquake breaks out
the three gather in the center of the
district with other civilians where they
all gawk in horror at the sight of a
titan larger than walmaria
the titan kicks a hole through
walmaria's gate sending massive pieces
of debris throughout the town
aaron and mikasa hurry home as titans
begin entering the district
arriving to find their house crushed by
a large rock and his mother trapped
beneath the rubble
as eren tries to help her a titan begins
approaching the collapsed house
haynes arrives intending to fight off
the titan but is overcome by fear
rather than fight the titan he takes
aaron and mikasa to safety and abandons
carla
haynes leaves aaron and mikasa on a boat
leaving the titan infested city
there aaron and mikasa witness an
armored titan destroying the back gate
of shigachinan
as aaron realizes that he can never
return home he vows to kill
every titan in existence aaron along
with mikasa and armin are sent to a
shelter for refugees from walmaria
soon after grisha arrives and finds
aaron who tells him that his mother was
eaten
after hearing this grecia takes aaron
into a nearby forest and instructs him
to go to the basement
before aaron can react grecia injects
him with a titan serum turning aaron
into a mindless titan
aaron instinctively eats his father
receiving his titan powers
including the dormant founding titan
after the fall of walmaria
aaron mikasa and armin briefly worked on
a farm with other survivors of walmaria
before reaching the proper age to enroll
in the military
two years later during the 104th rite of
passage conducted by instructor keith
shadis
aaron is ignored alongside others who
have clearly experienced trauma in their
past
before training aaron draws a crowd of
trainees at dinner time
describing the appearance of the
colossus and armored titans
he becomes sick as he remembers his
mother being eaten but when questioned
he attributes it to eagerness to begin
his training and kill all the titans
with the survey core
gene kirsten interrupts aaron and mocks
his decision
aaron does not admire jean's desire to
join the military police simply to live
in the interior walls
and the two prepared to fight each other
the bell signaling the end of dinner
rings
breaking the tension and the two drop
their disagreement with each other
the next day the trainees begin
practicing with vertical maneuvering
equipment
aaron utterly fails to keep himself
steady and takes extra tutoring from
armin amikaze
at dinner other trainees mock his
performance especially after his pledge
to kill all titans
back at the dorm connie and jean do not
offer any suggestions
and aaron visits reiner braun and
bertholdt hoover for help
although they are reluctant at first the
group bonds over their similar
experiences during the fall of walmaria
the three exchange tips and depart as
friends instructor shadis gives aaron
one last chance to pass his maneuvering
equipment test
before he will be shipped to the
landfills at first it appears aaron can
maintain his balance
but aaron quickly loses control and
falls over shadis has aaron switch
equipment with thomas wagner
and aaron finds that he is able to
easily balance himself and shadis
reveals that the equipment he had been
training with was defective
during hand-to-hand combat training
aaron admits to reiner that he finds it
unnecessary
claiming that it would be much easier to
run away when attacked by another human
than to engage them
reiner reprimands him for his attitude
and points aaron to annie
who is also slacking off egged on by
reiner aaron tries to attack annie with
his mock knife to punish her for
slacking off
and is quickly disarmed by her
unconventional fighting style
enthralled by annie's proficiency asked
to know who trained her
he is taken aback when she begins to
lecture him on the military's flaws
pointing out that it awards its most
talented trainees with positions far
away from the titans where their skills
would be most useful
annie's words continue to bother aaron
who becomes annoyed at the idea of
trainees trying to
improve their skills just to stay away
from the titans aaron confronts gene for
possessing such a mentality
which leads to a physical altercation
between the two aaron easily ends the
fight by replicating annie's moves
and proceeds to lecture gene for
slacking off during his training
aaron graduates in the top 10 of the
104th training corps
after graduation he is assigned to clean
the cannons atop walrose with sasha
connie and a few others there they
witnessed the return of the colossus
titan
who has not been seen in the last five
years while his fellow trainees are
paralyzed in fear at the sight of the
colossus titan
aaron attempts to kill it despite
getting close enough to the titan to
nearly slice the nape of its neck
it vanishes into thin air reinforcements
arrive and aaron's team is ordered to
return to the military's headquarters
for orders
aaron and armin are assigned to a squad
together as part of trust's middle guard
mikasa is unhappy to be assigned to a
different squad but she has sense when
aaron berates her for not obeying orders
despite their nerves aaron's squad
enters the battle in high spirits
viewing the upcoming battle as an
opportunity to prove their medal as
soldiers before they enter the survey
corps
however things immediately take a turn
for the worst when thomas wagner is
devoured
enraged aaron tries to kill the titan
only to be incapacitated by a second
titan biting off his leg
aaron regains consciousness just in time
to save armin from being eaten
being swallowed himself in the process
in the stomach of the titan
aaron comes across the dead or dying
soldiers who were devoured by the titan
as he remembers his goal to kill every
last titan alive
his anguish triggers his first
transformation into his attack titan
form
he proceeds to wreak havoc on all the
titans he finds in the process
he unknowingly saves mikasa's life from
another titan and is baited by armin
connie and mikasa to help fend off a
procession of titans from a storage
headquarters
for the compressed gas used to power
their maneuvering gear eventually
aaron appears to run out of energy and
begins to be overwhelmed by the titans
the sight of the titan that killed
thomas proves to be enough to drive
aaron to throw off the titans holding
him down
and kill the titan by biting its nape
off as soon as the massacre is over
aaron falls to the ground and his human
form emerges from the back of his titan
form's neck
he is retrieved by an overwhelmed mikasa
when he regains consciousness
aaron finds himself cornered with armin
and mikasa by a hostile military force
which has decided to execute him as a
possible threat due to his powers
aaron is unable to answer their
questions satisfactorily and they fire a
cannon at him and his friends
aaron instinctively grabs onto his two
friends and bites his own hand
partially transforming into a titan and
blocking the cannonball with the titan's
hand
while the cannon is being reloaded aaron
reveals to mikasa and armin that he
intends to use his power
to go over the wall and try to reach his
father's basement on his own
mikasa and armin both protest the
decision and aaron tells them that he
will stay behind
if armin can convince the amassed
soldiers not to kill him
armin's plea falls on deaf ears among
the soldiers who have cornered them
but the trio is saved by the arrival of
commander dot pixis
who intervenes on their behalf pixis
takes the three to the top of walrose
and questions aaron personally
aaron's answers satisfy pixis and the
man calls his subordinates to help
devise a plan to retake trust with
aaron's
powers a plan is made for aaron to use
his titan form to reseal trust's gate
with a boulder that is in the middle of
the district
upon his transformation to execute the
plan aaron loses control and attacks
mikasa before inadvertently rendering
himself
unconscious armin arrives on the scene
and convinces mikasa to go help
fend off the titans while he tries to
get through to aaron armin manages to
rouse aaron slightly by stabbing into
his titan's name and piercing his human
body
armand manages to bring aaron back by
reminding him of their desire to see the
world together
causing aaron to remember how he wanted
to join the survey corps and destroy all
the titans
aaron moves the stone and is able to
plug the hole in the wall at the
sacrifice of the rest of the team
members
they are saved from the desperate
situation after aaron's transformation
back to human by levi ackermann
after the events of trost aaron is
placed in the custody of the military
police
and kept chained in a dungeon prison
cell in the royal capital beneath a
courtroom
while he is there he is paid a visit by
commander erwin smith and levi
upon hearing his motive to kill titans
levi says he will accept him into the
survey corps
aaron is left there for some time before
being escorted by corps members to the
courtroom where he was tried with darius
zackly proceeding over events
during his trial the military police and
church of the walls call for his
dissection
and execution while the survey corps
argues in favor of using his power to
their advantage in scouting missions
after an outburst by aaron levi savagely
beats him to prove that aaron will not
pose a threat to him
it is decided his fate will be decided
after a test mission with the survey
corps
irwin thanks him for his cooperation
after joining the survey corps
aaron is assigned to levi's special
operations squad and sent to an
abandoned castle which had formerly
served as the base of operations for the
survey corps
while there he is tasked with cleaning
duty by levi while also helping squad
leader hanji zoe with their titan
experiments during one of the
experiments with his titan abilities
aaron is lowered into a well before
being told to transform into a titan in
case he loses control
however aaron is unable to activate his
titan abilities
he is eventually brought back to the
surface and has his wounds tended to by
levi's squad
later whilst bending over to pick up a
drop spoon with his injured hand
aaron accidentally triggers his titan
ability in a partial transformation
creating a titan hand in a small
explosion levi's squad surrounds aaron
demanding that he prove he is not a
threat to them
and the situation has to be defused by
levi and hanji
after the incident with the help of
hanji's deductions aaron learns that a
titan transformation requires him to
have a clear goal in mind
in addition to self-injury aaron meets
some of his classmates from the 104th
training corps who have opted to join
the survey corps he learns of marco's
death from jean
who lectures him about his
responsibilities to humanity
after a month of training aaron and the
survey corps embark on the 57th
expedition outside the walls during the
expedition
aaron is positioned at the center of the
long distance enemy scouting formation
where it is the safest however per
erin's orders
the knowledge of aaron's location within
the formation is given only to a select
few
it soon becomes apparent that something
is going wrong with the expedition
guade levi receives the news of the
decimation of the right wing of the
formation
and see backflares signaling the
presence of an abnormal in close
proximity
even though their position should be the
safest soon after the soldiers head
toward a titan forest
the central column of the scouting force
including aaron and levi's squad
are told to enter the forest while the
rest of the soldiers stand guard at the
perimeter of the forest
to prevent any titans from entering
after entering the forest
squad levi is set upon by a seemingly
intelligent female titan
who is able to dispatch pursuing
soldiers with ease seeing the soldiers
perish one by one
aaron is tempted to use his titan power
to save them levi gives him permission
but aaron decides to trust in his team
after recalling the trust they have had
in him as the titan approaches the squad
it is caught in an ambush set up by
irwin
aaron and the rest of his team excluding
levi right out of the forest
firm in the belief that the titan was
captured and her human self
apprehended the squad stands by and
discussed erwin's decision not to tell
the soldiers about the plan
aaron wonders why is it that not even
the elite soldiers were told about it
seeing a flare that indicates the core
is retreating the squad begins making
their way out of the forest
they notice another signal flare fired
in response believing it to be levi's
however the mysterious soldier kills
gunther and then transforms into the
female
titan to resume her pursuit of aaron the
remaining three team members tell aaron
to go on while they attack the female
titan
aaron agrees to retreat but regrets his
decision when the titan manages to
overpower and kill them
filled with regret aaron transforms and
engages the female titan
even though he initially had the upper
hand against the crippled female titan
aaron quickly expends all of his energy
and ultimately loses the fight
his human form is eaten by the female
titan just as mikasa arrives on the
scene
working with levi mikasa is able to
rescue aaron from the titan
the survey corps returns to walrose in
defeat due to the mission's failure
the military orders that aaron be turned
over to the government
before aaron can be handed over to the
military he is led in on a plan by irwin
to capture the female titan
whom armin has deduced to be annie
leonhart of the 104th
aaron is initially shocked and angry at
the accusation refusing to believe that
such a betrayal by one of his fellow
trainees is possible
however he is forced to acknowledge that
the fighting style the female titan
exhibited
was exactly the same as annie's
reluctantly he agrees to participate in
the plan to capture her
after armin convinces annie to join them
in a squirting errand out of stewis
district
they lead her to the entrance to an
underground tunnel aaron begs her to
join them and prove her innocence
but annie refuses several soldiers
ambush annie and she transforms forcing
aaron and his friends underground
aaron tries to go into titan form by
injuring himself but cannot
due to shock and disbelief at annie's
betrayal and his friendship with annie
making him unwilling to fight her
as mikasa and armin depart to attempt to
lead annie away
aaron is reminded of the lives annie
took as the female titan
as well as his vow to exterminate the
titans allowing him to finally overcome
his inhibitions
and transform into his titan form even
though aaron is in better control of his
titan and is equipped
with knowledge of his opponent this time
around he is ultimately no match for
annie's superior fighting technique and
hardening ability
he manages to throw annie into some
buildings but gets his right leg taken
off by a hardened kick from annie
who proceeds to slam him into a building
and pummel his head repeatedly with her
heart and fist
annie attempts to climb wall sheena to
escape but has her fingers severed by
mikasa causing her to fall back to the
ground
where she is set upon by aaron who holds
her down as core soldiers pry open her
nape
when wall rose is supposedly breached
aaron is among one of the teams within
the area to survey the wall for the
supposed breach
aaron is appalled to learn that minister
nick helped keep the colossus titans
inside the walls
secret and begs him to tell them
anything else he might know
nick proves to be tight-lipped and hanji
instead decides to inform aaron of their
plan to try
to replicate the female titan's
hardening ability in aaron
so that he can use his own titan's body
to seal wall rose
after learning from nick that crystal
lens will be able to divulge more
secrets about the walls
aaron accompanies hanji's squad to
utgard castle to save the soldiers
trapped there
they arrive just in time to save their
comrades excluding the members of squad
mike who have already died
during the rescue aaron kills his first
titan while in human form
but is scolded for breaking cover and
endangering himself
in the aftermath aaron is among the
soldiers on top of the wall recovering
from the ordeal at utgard
he asks about amir's condition before
going to help an injured reiner climb
the wall
as he helps armin up aaron tries to
check on reiner who begins complaining
about his repeated near-death
experiences
haynes arrives with news that there is
no hole or breach in the wall
prompting aaron to question if hanes is
drunk as saints orders them to stay on
standby in tross district
reiner asks to speak with aaron in
private leading aaron away
reiner reveals that he and bertholdt are
the armored and colossus titans
explaining that they will need to
continue their attacks on the walls if
aaron returns to their hometown with
them
aaron recalls hanji inquiring about
reiner and berthold potentially being
accomplices to annie
and tries to persuade reiner that he is
tired and simply not thinking straight
in response to aaron's disbelief reiner
removes the bandage on his arm and
reveals that his wounds are regenerating
mikasa attempts to intervene and protect
aaron but reiner and berthold transform
into their titan forms and attack
reiner grabs aaron while bertholdt
kidnaps amir and aaron disgusted by his
former friends
transforms himself aaron and reiner
grapple with one another while hanji's
squad attempts to take bertholdt down
aaron grows increasingly angry as he
remembers all of the pain reiner and
bertholdt inflicted on paradise
but he is unable to do any damage to
reiner with brute force due to the
latter's armor
instead he opts to use annie's fighting
techniques
grappling with reiner until he locks his
foe in a submission hold
as aaron holds reiner he focuses
pressure on one of reiner's arms
breaking the armor around the joints and
tearing the arm off completely
with reiner crippled aaron falls back to
the wall where hanji orders him to find
a way to destroy reiner's legs so that
he can flee without being pursued
aaron is caught off guard by reiner
attacking him head on but he manages to
lock reiner in another submission hold
as mikasa slashes reiner's legs aaron
begins applying pressure to his nape
causing its armor to crack however
before he can break reiner out of his
titan
reiner begins roaring causing berthold's
titan to roll off the top of the wall
landing atop both of them aaron and amir
are taken to the titan force by reiner
and bertholdt
he attempts to transform into his titan
form in spite of losing his arms but
amir points out that they are surrounded
by titans and have no maneuvering
equipment to escape
as they wait to depart at sundown emir
and aaron discover that reiner has
developed a split personality due to the
guilt of betraying his comrades
aaron is enraged thinking that reiner
has no right to feel sorry for himself
after what he has done
reiner and berthold tried to offer aaron
and amir a chance to join them in order
to protect their loved ones
but aaron furiously refuses and blames
both reiner and berthold for causing the
hardship he has had to endure
aaron continues to violently resist his
captors causing reiner to knock him out
his unconscious form is strapped to
barthold's back to be carried
aaron awakes in the midst of an attempt
by the survey corps to rescue him and
immediately begins resisting his captors
again in an attempt to free himself from
pure titans which have begun to attack
him
reiner is forced to stop using his hands
to cover aaron and bertholdt
exposing them and giving mikasa the
opportunity to attack bertholdt
as she rushes forward berthold dodges
and aaron tries in vain to warm mikasa
of a titan behind her
armin distracts bertholdt giving aaron
enough time to cut aaron free from his
captors
mikasa then grabs him before landing on
their horses as they flee
a large titan is sent flying and creates
a large explosion of dust
this causes some soldiers to fall off
their horses including aaron and mikasa
as the two pick themselves up they are
horrified to see the titan which ate
carla approaching them
hayne steps forward to protect aaron and
mikasa while he distracts the titan
aaron shouts from acosta to free him
believing he is the only one who can
save their lives but when he tries to
transform into a titan
nothing happens because he is still
recovering from his injuries
he is devastated when haynes gets eaten
devastated the thought that nothing
has changed from when he was 10 and was
powerless to save either his mother or
haines
mikasa attempts to reassure him telling
aaron that she wants to thank him for
teaching her how to live
and for wrapping his muffler on her
which she always wears filled with
newfound conviction
aaron vows to mikasa that he will wrap
the muffler around her as many times as
he needs to
in a desperate attempt aaron punches the
smiling titan in the hand as it reaches
for him
aaron screams and another titan attacks
the smiling titan elsewhere around them
the titans that were fighting the
soldiers turn and start running to the
smiling titan
surrounding and devouring it aaron takes
advantage of the situation and flees
carrying mikasa on his back
when reiner and bertholdt pursue him he
screams again and the titans turn to
attack them
aaron and the unified military group
managed to return to wall rose
armin notes how aaron seemingly
controlled the titans on the way back
but aaron is not confident in the
ability while aaron tries to remember
exactly what happened and how
jean tells him that whether it was worth
paying the price to rescue him will
depend on what aaron does going forward
aaron finds it odd to be lectured by
gene but recognizes that he is right
and vows to no longer hesitate
approximately one week later
he and the new squad levi move into a
secluded cabin
levi begins a meeting with his and hanji
squads announcing their plan to use
aaron's hardening to seal walmaria
at levi's request hanji begins testing
aaron's hardening abilities
but little success is had aaron fails to
show any signs of hardening and the
longer he tries
the more malformed his titan body
becomes aaron is discouraged by the
results but hanji and levi managed to
cheer him up
by reminding him that they learned a lot
about his abilities and limitations
after receiving word from irwin aaron
moves out along with the rest of levi's
squad and heads to their rendezvous
point in tross district
however he does not accompany them
inside instead
he waits with astoria in an undisclosed
location
the two of them bond over dreams they
cannot remember and expectations they
cannot meet historia notes that the
others must be disappointed by how empty
her true self is compared to her krista
persona
and aaron tells her that he likes her
new personality more than her old one
one morning aaron remembers a new detail
from his time with bertholth reiner and
emir and takes the information to hanji
hanji departs with the information to
take to irwin and anifa returns with a
message from the night before
erwin's plan to have historia take the
throne since the reece family is the
true
royal family to lure out rod reese aaron
and historia are handed over to the
reeves company to be delivered to the
military police
aaron awakes in a large crystalline
cavern gagged and restrained by change
atop a raised platform
as he struggles to break free he spots
astoria approaching below him
he is glad to see she is safe and
historia assures him that her father has
been misunderstood
having only acted in ways that are
beneficial for humanity aaron finds the
cavern they are in familiar and rod
suggests that he and historia lay their
hands on aaron's back to help him
remember
when they do aaron begins seeing his
father gracious memories and is stunned
to learn that he ate his own father
once the three of them are alone rod
opens a sachel and reveals a syringe
which aaron recognizes as the same kind
his father had used on him
rod explains that the founding titan's
powers can only be fully utilized by a
member of the reece family
kenny overhearing rod's words as he
returns is distraught to learn he will
not be able to use frida's power if he
devours aaron
intending to force aaron and dystoria to
battle each other over possession of
frieda's power
kenny cuts open aaron's forehead so that
he will be able to transform
before retreating to a safe distance
however aaron refuses to transform
heartbroken to learn that frida could
have put an end to the titans and
prevented so many of the deaths that had
occurred since the fall of walmaria
aaron begs historia to eat him so that
she can use the power that his father
stole to save humanity
moved by aaron's words historia
incapacitates her father and begins
freeing aaron from the restraints that
still hold him
to aaron's shock and despair as rod
transforms himself into a titan aaron
begs historia to allow her father to eat
him
historia refuses explaining that even if
she is an enemy to humanity
she is still aaron's friend she is blown
back by the winds created from rod's
transformation
but levi anti-squad arrive in time to
save her and get the keys to aaron's
chains
the ceiling begins caving in due to the
sheer size of rod's titan and the
squad's escape is blocked
aaron realizes that everyone with him is
going to die
as the squad considers ways to escape
aaron apologizes for being useless and
levi tells him that he has a choice to
make
spurred by levi's words aaron grabs a
bottle labeled armor that had fallen out
of rod satchel and bites into it
after transforming into a titan aaron is
able to harden it and reinforce the
structural integrity of the cavern
around it
the squad climbs out of the ruined
cavern and regroups to chase after rod
who has become an abnormal titan twice
the size of the colossus titan
aaron still considers being eaten by rod
to save humanity
but historia argues that the rhys family
has already tried on doing the
brainwashing and
once rod has the founding titan's power
he can alter everyone's memories so they
have no interest in restraining him
historia argues that taking away the
reece family's ability to alter memories
was the only way to save humanity
prompting aaron to remember his father's
words from right before he injected him
his father asked him to learn to control
this power to save mikasa
armin and everyone else they meet up
with aaron and his forces
and the soldiers all proceed to orvood
district to intercept rod's titan
aaron helps the survey corps stack
barrels of gunpowder together on a net
of rope
he watches historia stand up to irwin
and admires how strong she has become
compared to him
feeling melancholy that humanity has to
depend on someone like him
he spots children in orvid who remind
him of himself as a child
and thinks back to when the colossus
titan appeared armin tells him that it
will be different from before
because this time the soldiers on the
wall can fight back
aaron punches himself to try beating out
his feelings of uselessness
when rod's titan arrives and pulls
itself up to the wall
aaron transforms into his titan form he
takes the net stuffed with barrels and
shoves it into the open mouth of the
titan which is hot enough to make the
gunpowder ignite
this causes the titan's head and neck to
explode and enables the survey core
soldiers to attack the flying chunks of
meat in hope of destroying the nape
two months after historia becomes queen
aaron and the other members of the 104th
volunteer at an orphanage that she has
started
as erin helps historia she asks about
the progress of his hardening
experiments
aaron says they are going well but wants
to speed up the training before reiner
and bertholdt come back
she asks what he would do if they meet
up again and aaron says he will have to
kill them aaron compliments estoria for
the work she has done
prompting mikasa to abruptly interrupt
the conversation and take aaron's load
away from him
thanks to aaron's hardening experiments
the executioner from hell is developed
giving soldiers a reusable weapon to
safely kill titans without risking their
lives
however creating the materials for one
puts a strain on aaron's body
as aaron and his friends eat dinner in
the mess hall aaron recalls the events
of the past few months
particularly those concerning emir and
how she said her life was like a
nightmare when she was a titan outside
of the walls
he wonders if there was a time when he
was like that too but all he remembers
is what his father saw when aaron ate
him
gene advises that aaron focused on
remembering the identity of the survey
core
soldier from his father's memories jane
jokes that a headbutt from their
instructor would bring the memory back
and aaron realizes that the man his
father had seen was instructor keith
shadis the next morning aaron and his
comrades visit keith shadis their former
instructor
aaron asks him to tell them all that he
knows and keith tells him how he met
grecia and everything he knows about him
keith confesses that he is nothing more
than a bystander and that he has no
power to change things
the day before the operation to retake
walmaria the soldiers are having a great
dinner in order to ready them for the
operation
aaron and connie are forced to restrain
sasha to keep her from eating everything
the two reflect on how much things have
changed in three months since the battle
of trust
jean starts a fight with aaron by
insulting him and their fight is
eventually stopped by levi
after the fight aaron armin and mikasa
have a conversation about their future
they talk about how strong and weak
people need to combine their abilities
in order to succeed
after mistaking a garrison with hanes
mikasa wonders if they will be able to
go back to easier times when they retake
walmaria
aaron answers that it may not be
possible that is the reason why they
must make them pay
the next morning the soldiers are ready
to travel they get very surprised when
they see that the civilians are cheering
them
finally erwin orders the start of the
operation and aaron travels towards
shiganshinan along with squad levi
while traveling on foot under the cover
of night aaron apologizes to mikasa who
is escorting his horse in addition to
her own
but she insists that he save his energy
so that he can seal while maria
aaron is surprised to find himself
shaking in anticipation
he insists that he is just shaking from
the cold but armin reassures him that it
is normal to feel scared of the titans
and reminds aaron of when he was nearly
eaten during the battle of trust
aaron reveals that he sacrificed himself
to save armin that day
because he had remembered the first time
armin told him about the outside world
which had caused him to realize just how
much the titans had taken from the
humans
arriving in shiganshinon the core
soldiers quickly scale while maria with
their vertical maneuvering equipment
soaring over while maria aaron
transforms into his titan form and uses
his hardening abilities to seal its hole
mikasa retrieves him and carries him
back to the top of the wall
while going to meet up with the rest of
the core hanji orders aaron's squad to
take up positions along the top of the
wall after observing a signal flare
fired by irwin
to aaron's shock reiner emerges from the
inside of the wall and kills a core
soldier before being attacked by levi
as reiner transforms into his titan form
aaron is surprised again by the sudden
appearance of an army of titans on the
outskirts of shigachinan
with the beast's titan leading them on
irwin's orders
aaron descends into shiganshinan where
he changes into his titan form and acts
as bait to draw reiner's attention
after leading reiner away from walmaria
aaron begins to engage him
using his new hardening abilities to
cover his fists in armor
although he initially has the upper hand
against reiner aaron is momentarily
overpowered and pinned to the ground
he manages to regain control of the
fight and throw reiner off of him and
into an area where hanji's squad can
attack
as aaron watches hanji's squad blinds
reiner with their thunderspheres before
blowing open his titan forms nape
and apparently killing him after being
informed that berthold is approaching
hanji orders aaron and his comrades to
retreat from reiner's immediate vicinity
to avoid the blast from bertholdt's
transformation
after armin fails to negotiate with
bertholdt bertholt transforms into his
titan form and aaron uses his titan form
to shield his comrades from the blast
armin gives control of the squad to jean
and aaron begins to retreat from
berthold's position on gene's orders
using a nearby building to keep himself
hidden aaron attempts to draw his
attention away from walmaria and the
survey corps's remaining soldiers
bertholdt ignores him and aaron and his
comrades are left with no choice but to
engage him
as his comrades flank bertholdt aaron
grabs one of bertholdt's legs and
attempts to push him back
bertholdt simply kicks aaron into the
side of walmaria leaving him
incapacitated
after armin wakes him up aaron
reluctantly goes along with armin's plan
pretending to fall down to the ground
and become immobile in front of the
north gate while armin pretends to act
shocked escaping his titan form after
hardening it
aaron then grapples onto the nape of the
colossus titan slices it open
and yanks berthold out once bertholdt is
incapacitated
aaron finds armin's charred body aaron
laments that he could not prevent armin
from being killed
he notices zeke closing in on him and
threatens to kill berthold if zeke comes
any closer
to aaron's shock zeke claims that he has
been enslaved by his father grisha's
ideology
and promises to save him before aaron
can question him zeke retreats as levi
arrives
noticing that armin is still breathing
aaron begs levi to use the titan serum
on him
levi initially agrees before deciding to
give it to irwin upon learning that the
commander is still alive
he tries reminding levi of all that
armad accomplished as reasons that he
should be spared
levi ultimately chooses armin as armin
returns to his human form after
devouring bertholt
aaron and the 104th go to reunite with
him
when armin wakes up aaron explains what
has transpired to him
including berthold's death he hanji levi
and mikasa make their way to his
basement
however they discover that the key
krisha had given him does not fit the
lock
levi kicks down the door and they enter
an office it seems to be nondescript
until mikasa finds a keyhole in
greisha's desk
aaron tries the key on it and it opens
to reveal a drawer that appears to be
empty
they find a false bottom in the drawer
and underneath it are preserved books
aaron with mikasa opens one of them and
finds a picture of a family
on the back of it is a message of grecia
that the picture is called a photograph
and that humanity has not perished upon
returning victorious to the walls
aaron and mikasa are placed in detention
for disobeying orders from levi and
hanji
while serving his sentence he helps
armin verify the contents of grecia's
books regarding the outside world
and the true nature of the titans by
comparing them with his memories that
grecia passed down to him
during one of his nightmares he has
started the way with the realization
that dina
grisha's first wife was the smiling
titan who had devoured his mother
hanji and levi released aaron and mikasa
from detention 10 days early
informing them that their punishment was
only to set an example to the public
and that their help is needed to chart a
new course for the survey corps in light
of the new revelations about the outside
world
aaron and the survivors attend a meeting
with the rest of the military
including the queen to discuss the
results of the expedition to
shiganshanan and the information about
the outside world recovered from
grecia's books
during the meeting aaron realizes that
the reason he was able to activate the
founding titan's power in the past
was because he had physical contact with
dina fritz a member of the royal
family aaron chooses to withhold the
revelation reasoning that it is not the
proper occasion to discuss such a
controversial idea
especially if it involves having
historia turn into a titan so he can
control the founding titan
the surviving members of the survey
corps later attend a ceremony to be
commemorated with medals for their
bravery and success in chicago
before the ceremony begins flock forster
confronts armin about the decision to
save him over irwin
angering aaron an argument begins and
gene is forced to separate the two
before it can escalate
armin dejectively agrees with flock and
aaron attempts to comfort him by
reminding him of his dream to see the
outside world
reminding him of all the sights they
will see beyond the walls aaron begins
to remind armin of the freedom that is
waiting for them outside the walls
only to be given pause by the memory of
his aunt phase grisly death in marley
as the ceremony begins and the survivors
receive their medals from historia
aaron is lost in contemplation on the
state of the outside world
he would be happy to give up his life to
save paradise from the threat of marley
but he is unwilling to sacrifice anyone
else's life to do so
unsure of what to do next aaron receives
his medal from historia and kisses her
hand
receiving his father's memories of the
night he killed the rhys family
along with his father's memories of that
night aaron also receives memories from
himself
sent to his father from the year 854 via
the attack titan
effectively allowing him to see the
future the memories he receives reveal
that he will
in four years time use the founding
titan to unleash the colossus titans
enclosed in paradise's walls
and use them to wipe out 80 of humanity
outside the walls
aaron is left horrified by the
realization of what he will eventually
do
in roughly a year the titan guillotine
vanquishes all titans within walmaria
shiganshugan district is repopulated and
the survey corps hold their first
expedition beyond the walls in six years
the survey corps encounters a deformed
titan who had been crawling towards the
wall
and aaron identifies the titan as a
former compatriot the survey corps
follows the deformed titans trail until
they reach the edge of paradise island
the cervicorp go down to the beachfront
dismounting their horses and taking off
their boots
armin is overjoyed by the ocean but
aaron solemnly notes
that the other side of the ocean does
not hold freedom as he used to believe
enemies exist on the other side of the
ocean and aaron wonders if killing
everybody across the ocean
will bring the people of the walls
freedom aaron works with hanji zoe and
the survey corps to prepare for marley
in action against paradis island
eventually the first scouting ship
arrives and aaron uses his titan form to
pick it up and beach it on the shoreline
at a meeting between members of the ldn
military aaron supports the plan made by
zeke yeager and reveals the encounter
with dina fritz that caused him to
activate the powers of the founding
titan
he explains to hanji and levi ackerman
that he stayed quiet so that historia
reese's life would not be threatened
over the next three years marley sends a
total of 32 scouting ships to paradise
island
all of which are destroyed by aaron and
armin alert while at a shooting range
aaron asks armin if he has seen anything
from berthold hoofer's memories that
could help them
armin ponders if it is possible for
paradise island and marley to resolve
their misunderstandings diplomatically
but aaron brushes him off
arguing that everyone still sees them as
devils he reaffirms his position that
paradise must strike the first blow in
order to buy the island
time aaron later attends a meeting
between kiyomi azumabido
from the nation of hizuru and the heads
of paradise on forming an alliance
when aaron hears that one of the three
paths of action would involve historia
succeeding zeke as the beast titan
he refuses to accept the plan in 853
while helping his friends assemble a
train line aaron is very disappointed to
hear that his uru has been unable to
find additional allies for them
mentioning that zeke only has two years
left to live before he dies
aaron ponders who should take his titan
when he himself must pass it on
his friends offer themselves but he
tells them that he wants them to live
long lives
roughly a year later flock allows yelena
to discreetly meet with aaron at least
once during a festival and trust
yelena explains zeke's plan to euthanize
the ldn race along with his plan to feed
his spinal fluid to the military's
officers
so that they will not be able to oppose
his or eren's movements
following his meeting with yelena aaron
meets with flock privately and tells him
that he wants them to pretend to
cooperate with zeke's plan
flock asks what he actually wants to do
while pretending to cooperate with zeke
and aaron tells flock his plan to use
the founding titan to kill everyone
outside of paradise erin meets with
historia and warns her that the military
police are planning to feed zeke to her
advising her to either fight or run to
avoid becoming one of the nine titans
historia refuses to oppose the mps
explaining that she is willing to
sacrifice herself if it will save
paradis
aaron is one of several survey corpsmen
who journeyed to marley's mainland to
meet with kyomi
although his companions are thrilled by
the new experiences beyond the walls
aaron remains stoic aaron explores
marley agonizing over the knowledge that
he will soon be responsible for killing
everyone
remembering carl fritz's desire for the
ldm people to die out
aaron admits that such an outcome would
lead to less deaths and finally rid the
world of titans but he finds himself
unable to accept such a fate
he finds a boy being beaten by merchants
for stealing and recognizes from his
memories that he is going to save the
boy
he attempts to convince himself not to
and leave knowing that he will
ultimately kill the boy himself in the
rumbling but he is unable to stop
himself from intervening
aaron returns the boy to his village
solemnly noting that he was unable to
change the future
in tears he apologizes to the boy the
boy returns to his tent just as mikasa
arrives to look for aaron
he brushes off her worried comments
about his reckless behavior instead
commenting on the similarities between
the boy's family and their experiences
when shiganshinan was breached
aaron asks mikasa why she displays so
much concern for him
and mikasa surprised claims it is
because they are family
they are joined by gene armin connie and
sasha and the group is welcomed into the
tent by the boy's family
spending the night drinking and
carousing the soldiers sit in on a
hearing between politicians to discuss
ld and mistreatment
when the speaker begins calling for the
hatred being shown towards aldiance to
be redirected towards the aldians living
on paradis
aaron quietly leaves the meeting before
the end of the marley mid-east war
aaron cuts off his own leg and gouges
out one of his eyes to infiltrate the
marley military as an injured ldn
soldier
after being knocked to the floor by a
terrified soldier he is helped up by
falco grease who points out that his
armband is on the wrong arm
using the alias of kruger aaron is
visited by falca while he is in the
hospital
he admits to falco that he has been
faking amnesia so that he will not be
discharged
and asks the boy to send a letter for
him from outside of the internment zone
so that the hospital will not figure out
that he is faking his illness
aaron says the letter is to his family
to let them know he is all right
during his stay in liberio aaron meets
with zeke and learns about the true
nature behind the ackermann clan lineage
aaron asks zeke if mikasa's headaches
are something every ackerman experiences
and zeke claims to have never heard of
such symptoms zeke tells aaron that he
does not believe that ackerman's truly
have ingrained behaviors towards a host
instead suggesting that mikasa simply
likes aaron aaron replies that he only
has four years left to live
and wishes for his friends to live
longer zeke asks if aaron would go
through with his plan to save the
subjects of amir by euthanizing them
aaron claims that their father was
mistaken and agrees with zeke's earlier
claim that grisha had brainwashed him
into following his plan
aaron laments that there would be no
suffering had the aldian's never been
born and agrees to work with zeke
aaron continues to receive visits from
falco who delivers more of his letters
during this time aaron learns that
reiner is still alive and his falco's
superior
after falco leaves one of the hospital's
doctors sits down next to aaron and
introduces himself as jaeger
the two talk about falco and jaeger asks
aaron to stop using falco to run errands
so that there would be no risk of
undoing the hard work that had returned
peace to the greece family
aaron asks jaeger if he has any regrets
about his family causing the doctor to
have a mental breakdown
just before the start of the typer
festival aaron leaves the hospital and
takes up residence in a building near
the stage willie tiber will be
performing a play on
in root he runs into falco and asks the
boy to bring reiner to him
upon reiner's arrival he asks aaron why
he is in marley
and aaron responds that he is there for
the same reason as reiner
he has no choice revealing that he has
already slit his hand in preparation to
transform if need be
aaron insists that reiner sit with him
to listen to the play
aaron regenerates his leg and apologizes
to falco for deceiving him
admitting that letters falco sent were
not to his family but to his ally
stationed in marley overhearing willie
claimed that he is a threat to marley's
peace
aaron admits that he is indeed the bad
guy but argues that the warriors were
also the bad guys when they invaded
walmaria
aaron asks why reiner and the others
broke the wall and reiner says that it
was so they could capture the founder
and save the world
reiner asks if aaron has come to kill
him and aaron admits that he has seen
that there are both good and evil people
in marley
he admits that he understands the
turmoil reiner went through
causing the latter to break down and ask
that aaron kill him
helping reiner to his feet aaron says
that he now understands that they are
the same and declares that he will
continue until he wipes
out his enemy transforming into the
attack titan
aaron breaks out of the building and
kills willy he flings himself on top of
the military high command in the crowd
killing them as aaron rampages the
warhammer titan emerges and he attacks
it before it can fully transform
it appears that he has the upper hand
until a hardened pillar impales him
the warhammer titan finishes its
formation and constructs a hammer to
fight aaron
aaron breaks the pillar trapping his
titan only to find the ground covered in
barbed spikes
preventing him from lifting his feet
aaron hardens his titan's hands in an
attempt to block the warhammer's next
strike but fails
and the attack titan's head is sheared
away aaron emerges from his titan's nape
and calls for mikasa who attacks the
warhammer at the same time the rest of
the survey corps attacked the marlin
military
the warhammer titan survives mikasa's
attack and fires a pike of its hardened
skin towards them
aaron comes up with a plan to defeat and
eat the warhammer titan
and ask mikasa to distract it long
enough for him to enact it
as mikasa fights the warhammer titan
aaron remembers that the titan's body
materialized from its feet
rather than its nape and deduces that
its human body is located somewhere
underground
transforming back into the attack titan
he sees a hole in the street from where
a long cable of flesh comes out
attached to the warhammer titan aaron
reaches in and grabs the crystallized
body of the younger sister of willie
severing her connection and disabling
the warhammer as aaron is about to eat
the warhammer
the jaw titan appears behind him and
bites aaron's neck
with levi's help aaron smashes the titan
against the building and tries to take
it off his back
but it manages to flee because of the
distraction aaron fails to notice that
the warhammer has been generating a new
titan body
and he is impaled in a tree-like
structure made of hardened skin
trapped aaron breaks his hand free and
attempts to consume the warhammer's user
once more
when he bites the crystal he breaks his
titan's jaw on the hardened surface
the jaw titan runs across the plaza to
assault aaron
and resorts to using its claws to strike
him during the attack
aaron blocks a slash from the titan
using the younger sister of willy's
crystal
noticing that the attack successfully
produced cracks in the crystal aaron
devises a plan to use the jaw titan to
get to the younger sister of willy
mikasa cripples the jaw titan's legs in
a surprise attack
allowing aaron to grab it and disable it
before jamming the crystal into its
mouth and using its jaws to break
through
he successfully kills the younger sister
of woolly consuming the fluids from her
body and giving himself the powers of
the warhammer titan
he moves to finish off the jaw titan but
is stopped by the arrival of an
incomplete armored titan
aaron punches reiner but reiner manages
to rescue the jaw titan
aaron emerges from his titan proclaiming
that their mission is done
leading mikasa to ask that they go back
home as they grapple up to the airship
aaron promises reiner that they will
meet again
once on the airship aaron is met by levi
who kicks him and orders that he be
restrained
aaron does not resist but insists that
nothing in his letter was wrong
aaron waits in a room with zeke and
yelena aboard the airship when jean
arrives with falco and gabby saying that
gabby
shot sasha hanji berates aaron for
having forced the survey court to
accommodate his plans and abusing their
trust
aaron is unrepentant saying that the
destruction of the marley and military
leadership has bought them time
when connie comes in to announce that
sasha has died aaron asks about her
final words
hearing that it was meat aaron begins to
laugh
after returning to paradise aaron is
taken to a cell underground in
accordance with his arrest
as he cleans himself up aaron mutters
that paradise needs to continue fighting
hanji arrives and notes that aaron was
talking to himself before attempting to
make small talk with him
aaron demands to know what hanji visited
him for and hanji chastises aaron for
inflaming the rest of the world against
paradise with his attack
aaron reveals that he stole the power of
the warhammer titan in liberio
and claims that he can free himself
anytime grabbing hanji through the bars
of his cell
aaron demands to know what hanji can do
to him and asks if there is any other
way for them to act
at roughly the same time darry exactly
is killed by a bomb in his office
aaron uses his titan abilities to escape
from his cell
after escaping aaron meets up with the
yeagerists a group consisting of flock
and the other recruits who sided with
him during his incarceration
aaron hears the proposal put forth by
commander pixis and refuses the offer
he then learns from one of his followers
that hanji and his friends are gathered
at a nearby restaurant
arriving at the restaurant he instructs
flock to restrain and move them while he
speaks to mikasa armin and gabby
aaron speaks to them in a private room
claiming to want to solve things
peacefully
armin asks if zeke and yelena have
convinced him to join their side
but aaron brushes him off and claims
that everything he has done has been his
desire
mikasa insists that he is being
controlled but aaron ignores her
aaron reveals to armin that he is aware
of the latter's frequent trips to visit
annie
and suggests he is being unknowingly
influenced by the memories bertholdt had
of her
when mikasa goes to defend armin aaron
reveals that he has learned about her
family lineage from zeke
and claims that the only reason she has
stayed by his side is due to her
instincts to protect her host
she explains that ackermans once
awakened often suffer unexpected
headaches due to their true self
fighting the urge to protect their
recognized host and claims the true
mikasa
died the day he saved her from her
kidnappers aaron proclaims that he has
always hated people like mikasa
obedient slaves that do nothing but
follow orders armin attacks aaron but
his point is proven when mikasa
instinctively grabs armin and slams him
into the table
armin manages to punch him anyway and
aaron responds by beating armin into
submission
he orders that they and gabby be taken
away but becomes briefly enraged when
armin calls him a slave
later aaron takes two soldiers and
visits gabby in her holding cell and
offers to help her save
falco in exchange for her issuing a call
for help to marley to root out any
possible spies
aaron is caught by surprise when one of
the soldiers aims a pistol at him after
stabbing the other in the throat
he is unfazed by piac's threat of
shooting him reminding her that her
mission is to presumably take him alive
however piek claims that she wishes to
join him not trusting her intentions
aaron pricks his finger and orders her
to prove herself to him and the
jaegerists
when piek offers to reveal where her
fellow infiltrators are
aaron heals his finger and orders piek
and gabby to be handcuffed together
on the roof he prepares to injure
himself again and orders piek to reveal
her fellow infiltrators
she points at aaron himself and the jaw
titan suddenly attacks aaron
taking both of his legs transforming
aaron spots a fleet of marley and
airships approaching their location
aaron trades several blows with the jaw
titan before it retreats
aaron is perplexed at marley's decision
to launch a counter-attack so soon after
the raid on liberio
despite yelling up pleading with him to
flee underground aaron decides to fight
marley on his own
noticing reiner transforming into the
armored titan while parachuting from an
airship aaron deduces that was
responsible for marley's quick response
to the liberio attack
and the two proceed to engage each other
aaron initially overpowers reiner
using his superior fighting skills and
hardening to break through reiner's
armor plating
reiner manages to briefly stun aaron and
the jaw titan attempts to ambush him
from behind
but aaron uses the warhammer titan's
abilities to repel them
aaron is shot in the head with a round
from marley's anti-titan artillery
leaving his motor skills severely
impaired
aaron is able to generate more spikes to
stop the jaw titan's attacks but is shot
in the head a second time
stunned aaron is unable to dodge
reiner's attack and is skewered by one
of the spikes generated from the ground
despite this he manages to generate a
third set of spikes to impale reiner
once more
and smacks the jaw titan out of the air
when it tries to attack him from behind
aaron tries to hold off reiner and
manages to rip through the ladder's jaw
but reiner continues to incapacitate
aaron until he is saved by a projectile
thrown by zeke from atop the wall
with zeke's arrival aaron begins trying
to reach him in hopes of activating the
powers of the founding titan
while zeke keeps marley's warriors at
bay as he grows closer to zeke's
position
aaron is set upon by the jaw titan once
again but makes short work of him
repeatedly slamming down on the titan's
head and
nape however this distracts him long
enough for another anti-titan artillery
round to be fired into his head again
and for reiner to catch up to him and
begin grappling with him
the fighting is momentarily interrupted
by the arrival of colt and falco who
reveal
that falco has accidentally ingested
zeke's spinal fluid
zeke is undeterred and screams ordering
a transformed falco to attack reiner
falco's pure titan does not prove to be
enough to force reiner to let go of
aaron
so aaron exits his titan and begins
running to zeke on foot
however before he can reach his brother
aaron is decapitated by a blast from an
anti-titan artillery rifle
as his head lands in his brother's hand
aaron suddenly finds himself standing
before a pillar of light in an unknown
land
he is greeted by a chained zeke who
informs aaron that they are standing in
the coordinate
zeke explains that he was able to bring
the two of them into the unknown land
by touching aaron's head in the moments
before he could die they have
finally unlocked the founding titan's
power aaron notices a young girl
approaching them and zeke informs him
that the girl is a mere fritz
zeke encourages him to take control of
amir and activate their plan to
euthanize all aldians
but aaron inquires as to why he is
sitting there in chains zeke explains
that the chains are karl fritz's vow
keeping anyone with royal blood from
acting freely and again asks aaron to
begin their plan
however aaron reveals that he has no
intention of following zeke's plan
and was only using him to obtain the
founder's power aaron approaches amir
and requests he be given control of her
power
only to be ignored to aaron's horror
zeke reveals that during his time
waiting for aaron to arrive in the
unknown land
he discovered a way to erase carl
fritz's vow and that emir will only obey
people with royal blood
zeke chains aaron in place explaining
that he has been brainwashed by grecia
despite aaron's protests zeke promises
to free him and begins showing him
memories from greece's life
zeke systematically takes aaron through
different moments in gracious life on
paradise
detailing how grecia covertly used his
occupation as a doctor to gain
information on the royal family in spite
of the risk posed to his new family
aaron is largely unfazed by the memories
only surprised to learn that grecia
located the reese chapel years before he
actually attacked the family
and that he still thought of zeke years
after arriving to paradis
while zeke is reeling at the revelation
that their father still cared for him
aaron moves along to the next memory as
aaron and zeke continue through grisha's
memories
zeke asks why aaron betrayed him if he
was not brainwashed by grecia
aaron responds that he has always
believed in stealing the freedom of
anyone who opposes his own
aaron and zeke then go to the memory of
grisha writing about how humanity has
not perished beyond the walls and are
both caught off guard when grecia is
able to see zeke for a brief moment
aaron and zeke travel to greece's memory
of the day he stole the founding titan
from the rhys family
as he observes the exchange between his
father and frida reese aaron becomes
increasingly agitated by frida's claims
that the audience must take on the
world's wrath for the sins of their
ancestors
despite gracious declaration that he
will steal the founding titan from the
rhys family
aaron is disappointed and enraged to see
that his father cannot bring himself to
carry out his mission
to spur his father forward aaron reminds
grisha of his fellow restorationists and
fey
ordering him to finish what he has
started zeke returns the two brothers to
the present despite aaron's objection
that they have yet to see greisha's
final memories
aaron reveals that four years prior he
had been given a glimpse of his own
memories of the future
while peering into gracious memories and
zeke horrified
orders emir to sterilize the subjects of
emir desperate to stop zeke's plan
aaron is able to escape his chains by
severing his thumbs against the shackles
and racist to try and stop emir
he embraces her and begs that she give
him her power so that he can end the
world
promising that he will not force her to
help him he recognizes that she is
neither a slave nor a deity
she is only a human being and she has
the right to choose if she wants to
remain in the coordinate forever or help
him end it all
as zeke desperately tries to stop him
aaron asks amir if she was the one who
led him to the coordinate
using that she has been waiting two
thousand years for him to arrive
in shiganshinan aaron's body transforms
into the founding titan as
shiganshinan's walls begin to crumble
he then uses the founder's power to
telepathically communicate with all of
the subjects of amir
he reveals that the hardening of the
walls has come undone and declares that
the wall titans will destroy all life
outside the island
aaron and his titans arrive at marley's
coast to find it guarded by the global
allied fleet however
the fleet proves to be ineffective
against aaron's colossus titans and is
immediately wiped out
the land artillery on marley is also
unsuccessful in stopping the advancing
titans causing the soldiers to retreat
to higher ground
as his titans begin the destruction of
marley aaron remembers the death of his
mother and reiterates his desire to
destroy
every last one of his enemies in the
world while he is advancing
aaron summons each of his friends to
speak with him in paths individually
he reveals to each of them his true
intentions to become a threat to the
entire world
so that they can kill him and earn the
favor of the nations outside of paradise
he also reveals that his death will
permanently destroy the power of the
titans
causing all aldians trapped as pure
titans including connie's mother
to return to their human forms when
aaron speaks with mikasa
he shows her a vision of a possible
future in which they decided to run away
together while in marley and live out
the rest of their lives together in
peace and isolation after spending some
time together in the vision
aaron asks mikasa to forget him after
his death
when aaron speaks with armin he tries to
apologize for the way he treated him at
nicolo's restaurant
but armin says that he should be more
worried about apologizing to mikasa
armin worries that the world will try to
retaliate for what aaron did but aaron
reveals that he succeeded in wiping out
80
of the world's population before he was
stopped the nations will not be able to
launch any meaningful counter-attacks
for the foreseeable future
armin tries to insist that there was a
better way but aaron ignores his
protests and asks armin to follow him
aaron takes arm into a volcano to show
him the liquid fire that he read about
as a child
lava aaron reveals to armin that he has
come to understand that the reason emir
fritz remained survival to the royal
family
even centuries after her original
master's death is because she genuinely
loved him
despite the abuses she suffered by him
although he does not understand the
woman fully
he knows that it was mikasa who managed
to free her from her servitude
aaron claims to not know why mikasa is
important to amir
only that every action he has taken
since he received his future memories
has been done in the service of mikasa
freeing amir
as he reflects on everything he has done
aaron confesses to armin that he can no
longer think clearly
as the combination of past and future
memories in his head have rendered him
unable to distinguish what is past
present and future his warped
perspective of time has caused him to
take actions to ensure history should
play out the way he remembers it
even using his powers to go back in time
and influence dina fritz's titan to eat
his mother
aaron takes aaron to see the ocean and
asks him if he believes mikasa can move
on from him
aaron claims he does not know and armin
punches him enraged at the way he has
been treating mikasa
armin begins ridiculing aaron joking
that mikasa will forget about him
quickly and aaron finally breaks down
and admits that he does not want mikasa
to love anyone but him
after composing himself aaron confesses
that he does not want to die
armin tries to convince him that he can
keep living but aaron reminds him that
the world will never forgive what he has
done
as a ruined landscape of trampled
corpses appears before them
aaron confesses that he would have
continued rumbling even if his friends
had not tried to stop him
armin demands to know why but aaron
claims he does not know
aaron tells armin that he will be
temporarily erasing his memories until
his death and armand gives him a
seashell
thanking him for everything he has done
for paradise's sake
the two embrace and aaron tells armin
that he is confident armin will be able
to save humanity after his death
as he approaches fort salta aaron
summons mikasa
armin jean connie levi reiner and piek
into the past to speak to them
his former comrades beg him to stop the
rumbling but aaron tells them that he
has no intention of stopping
he explains that he will take all of the
world's freedom so he can achieve his
own
but he promises not to deny the
alliance's freedom to thwart his plans
however aaron reinforces his intent to
destroy the world
refusing to negotiate on any terms and
stating that the only thing to stop his
advance would be his death
marley and airships are launched from
fort sulta in an attempt to stop aaron's
advance and begin dropping bombs on his
titan
in response aaron dispatches the beast
titan to shoot them down
aaron and the beast make quick work of
the airships but his comrades arrive and
manage to evade the beast titan's
projectiles long enough to reach him and
engage him directly
as his friends attempt to reach his nape
and destroy it aaron and amir begin
generating more titans on his back to
defend him
despite this the soldiers eventually
managed to reach aaron's nape and blow
it up
severing his titan's head from its body
armin then transforms atop his titan in
an attempt to kill him
this proves to be ineffective and
aaron's head transforms again into a new
colossus form to continue its march
he is met by armin who chooses to engage
him in a hand-to-hand fight with his
colossus titan form
aaron once again proves to be the better
fighter between the two but armin
manages to immobilize him long enough
for mikasa to enter his titan's mouth
and kill aaron by severing his head from
the spine
before kissing him goodbye following his
death mikasa and armin decide to bury
aaron's head at the foot of the tree he
liked to nap
under outside of shigansternan district
and a small grave is made there for
aaron
which mikasa continues to visit years
later
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos